hello red jag nation its Greg Alva here
and I'm John we're gonna watch this
video that John saw an article about he
didn't watch the video and we saw Andrew
Gordon yesterday's like dude there's a
teaser for this thing do you got a watch
there's a very vindicating moment I was
like see he said so - it's just titled
Star Wars scene 38 reimagined unofficial
short scene teaser trailer I did
stig reshoot this or something yeah it's
been damned
[Music]
Wow the whole season is supposed to come
out at some point this year but oh wow
yeah whoo that's cool I hope they
released the whole movie and then just
throw that one back in its full context
in that moment yeah because I wasn't
sure we were watching at first we were
seeing the beginning of that and then
they started sure it's a different shots
like wait a minute
and that's awesome because for a lot of
people a new hope and Empire tends to be
their favorite ones one thing with a new
hope is that lightsaber fight is just
not that cool I know for its time it's
awesome to see but when you watch it now
you're like it not much really goes down
on that provide tremendous fight it's
just cool you had the technology to make
the laser swords go it wasn't that cool
of a fight and then now they're doing a
reimagine a ssin of it in costume with
the set and you get a little badass
myself I would ask fight a fight that
you probably wished it was like when you
look back on the movie now that's my
favorite thing is when one like fans do
stuff like this that other fans are like
well that we would want in the movie CG
Yoda but oh sweet yeah wait for this to
come out who's who's making this who is
are these people have X ITIN posts fix
it and posts or FX in it imposed
oh it's their first video they have oh
my goodness guys this is I cannot wait
to see this is gonna be awesome okay
I swear you're gonna hole see the whole
fight I can't wait for this yeah let's
go side by side going down yeah yeah
ditto ones a minute yeah subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
but I'll keep a lookout from when our
reaction to this videos out